bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt français dans cette tribune au
monde mais aussi une lettre du préfet du
nord adressé au premier ministre dans
laquelle ils parlent de l'impréparation
manifeste du bric site par les
britanniques
qu'est ce qu'il entend par là il est
important de noter dans le contexte de
dubaï cité notamment la le caractère
tardif des conclusions de l'accord sur
vos la sortie de la grande-bretagne du
royaume uni de l'union européenne la de
noter que force est de constater que les
métallique n'était pas en situation de
recréer une frontière susceptible dès le
1er janvier d'assurer la fluidité du
passage des personnes et des
marchandises
mais ce que nous souhaitons par cette
les villes que vous avez mentionné
c'est précisément que l'union européenne
se dote des conditions de contrôle pour
éviter que puisque nos frontières il ya
et puisque les normes ne sont plus les
mêmes et à dijon en ont décidé ainsi il
n'est pas en quelque sorte une
compétition portuaire mais qu'il y ait
une harmonisation des conditions du
contrôle entre les différentes places
portuaires de france et d'europe comme
porte d'entrée des produits transitant
par la grande beauté
alors on rappelle un ce que vous
craignez un s'est inscrit dans cette
tribune que les citoyens français et
européens consomment afin que ce qu'ils
consomment ne respectent pas les hauts
standards de protection sanitaire
assurée notamment par l'union européenne
c'est bien ça
oui bien sûr l'union européenne s'est
dotée d'une réglementation commune les
différents pays européens
la grande bretagne a souhaité en sortir
et donc aujourd'hui fait valoir une
règlement une réglementation
particulière qui n'est pas
nécessairement niveau de celle de
l'europe
il n'y a aucune raison que l'europe
n'est un s'aligner vers le pas et au
contraire elle doit d'exercer lé
contrôle nécessaires à garantir
les consommateurs de son espèce de son
espace européen
donc voilà une réalité européenne voilà
ce que c'est que ces deux une
réglementation exigeant sur la
protection des consommateurs et il n'y a
aucune raison que sous prétexte que
certains sont quelques uns des acteurs
économiques tout en quittant cet espace
de solidarité l'europe est là et bien
cela surfaces au détriment des
consommateurs et dans la compétitivité
de la compétition des ports n'est pas
que l'entrée des produits transitant par
la grande bretagne doivent être des
portes d'entrée soumises au contrôle d
identité de façon à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
de difficultés est en quelque sorte de
dumping sur la réglementation alors le
préfet du nord a dit craindre un que le
port de boulogne sur mer en perdre à
terme son statut de premier port de
pêche français compte tenu de la
réduction prévisible de la débarque à de
produits de la mer
c'est ce que vous risquez aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui nous avons eu un accord sur
le break site avec des négociations
futures sur des zones de pêche une
période de transition de cinq ans c'est
dire que l'accord est un accord cadre
qui appelle à de la vigilance et de
l'exigence de la part de l'europe et de
l'accompagnement de l'ensemble de la
filière
il est clair que un certain nombre de
zones poissonneuses et est virtualisé
non pas par l'entrée de la
grande-bretagne dans la cee de l'union
européenne avant même que la grande
bretagne ne soient membres de l'union
européenne et la posture de jackson sur
la volonté au de retour et une souris
main sur la mer va au delà même des
engagements qui étaient des engagements
européens dans ce que nous souhaitons
c'est qu'une rock soit faire la campagne
ces pêcheurs et que nous puissions avoir
une négociation ferme l'exigeante
notamment sur la façon dont la
grande-bretagne se comportera par
rapport au milieu marin par ceux ci à nu
la surpêche
si les britanniques vendelée
ap a cité de pêche à des pays tiers qui
lie à une surproduction sur
l'exploitation des espèces marines
alors c'est l'ensemble des marins qu'ils
soient britanniques qu'ils soient
européens qui dans les générations qui
viennent seront victimes de ce
comportement de marchandisation des
produits de la mer et donc de l'enjeu
naturel qui est que sont les ressources
maritimes
cédric que bédié merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous je rappelle que vous
êtes maire de boulogne-sur-mer président
de la communauté d'agglomération du
boulonnais merci à vous d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur arte france